move over Beyonce there's a new queen in
the Carter house The Lion King star just
dropped The Lion King the gift a
companion album to the remake of the
classic Disney flick that she executive
produced now fans are going nuts over
one song in particular that includes a
special collab with her daughter Blue
Ivy the song titled brown-skinned girl
also features wizkid and st. John but
it's blues vocals that steal the show
yep
that's a seven year old harmonizing like
a boss and get this blue is listed as a
singer and writer on the track never
change it for anybody is singing it's
safe to say beyonce and jay z's little
girl has some serious chops blue also
made a sweet cameo in the music video
for spirit off The Lion King soundtrack
yeah that's a seven year old achieving
the impossible stealing the spotlight
from Beyonce but this isn't the first
time Blue Ivy has given us all those
mommy-daughter feels she walked the red
carpet hand-in-hand with her mama at the
premiere of The Lion King and when she
was just 23 months old her sweet little
voice was featured on these 2013 song
blue
oh and remember when she clapped for her
mama on stage as she accepted the mtv
VMA video Vanguard Award
she's already sat front row Center at
the Grammy Awards not once but twice and
was even introduced to the world on
stage in her Mama's belly after an epic
dance filled performance
[Applause]
[Music]